und ich begrüße bei uns professor
hendrik strikt den direktor des
instituts für virologie an der
universität bonn
herzlich willkommen hier in unserem
studio wir achten auf distanz dass hier
nichts dummes passiert wie ordnen sie
das ein was die ministerpräsidenten und
die kanzlerin heute nachmittag
beschlossen haben also im wesentlichen
das kontaktverbot für alle gruppen
größer als zwei personen ist das aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht genau die
richtige maßnahme
nun wir haben ja die letzten tage sehr
viele maßnahmen eingeführt die los gegen
mit schulschließungen oder schließung
auch von größeren versammlungen über
unter tag über 1000 personen
man muss jetzt abwarten was passiert
weil man muss sich schon erstmal
anschauen ob eine der maßnahmen
überhaupt funktioniert wir wissen ja
dass das virus 6 bis manchmal 14 tage
inkubationszeit hat und dann werden wir
erst nach zwei drei wochen auch wirklich
merken ob es einen rückgang der
neuinfektionen gibt was wir jetzt sehen
werden auch in den nächsten tagen ist
ein weiterer anstieg der infektionen
weil die maßnahmen die vor zwei wochen
gefällt wurden die kommen sehen wir
jetzt erst in dem anstieg der infektion
also wir müssen abwarten und
wissenschaftlich ist es natürlich eine
gute maßnahme auf kontakt reduktion zu
gehen wir wissen wie das virus
übertragen wird aber wie gut die
maßnahmen greifen das wissen wir noch
nicht ich hatte jetzt eigentlich die die
hoffnung dass sie ein bisschen
zuversicht hier arbeiten könnten denn
wir verfolgen ja jetzt alle die die
zahlen der neuansteckungen her in
deutschland und da wird ja doch
vermittelt samstag/sonntag da sind die
neuansteckungen ein bisschen
zurückgegangen jetzt habe ich auch
gehört das liegt vielleicht nur daran
dass die gesundheitsämter sonntags nicht
so viel eingeben also ich hätte mich
auch gefreut wenn die neuinfektionen
zurückgegangen sind aber dann waren wir
selber auch sehr schnell klar dass die
gesundheitsämter heute und gestern auch
nicht offen hatten
nein es ist einfach epidemiologisch und
biologisch so dass alle maßnahmen die
jetzt getroffen werden wir den effekt in
10 14 vielleicht noch länger sehen
hagen sehen werden also ist es keinen
sofortigen effekt daher kann ich auch
nicht mit zuversicht kommen und alles
was wir nur sagen können ist eine unter
oder zurückblicken können auf die daten
sind von sehr alten epidemien vor diese
vernetzung und diese ja diese ideen noch
gar nicht so wirklich zu tage gekommen
sind damit nicht die falschen begriffe
unterwegs sind das was jetzt beschlossen
wurde ist ja keine ausgangssperre jeder
von uns darf nach wie vor aus zum
einkaufen darf ins büro oder in den
betrieb faden wenn das nicht ins home
office verlagert da ist und man darf mit
dem hund raus gehen und man darf joggen
spazierengehen ist das richtig weil das
komplette die komplette ausgangssperre
wahrscheinlich kontraproduktiv wäre das
ist ganz genau richtig und ist es auch
kein verbot zu kontakten wir
digitalisieren einfach mehr unsere
kontakte und vielleicht besteht darin
auch eine chance dass wir jetzt vermehrt
eben darauf setzen dass wir nicht auch
bei größeren arbeitstreffen zueinander
kommen in einem großen raum sondern eben
über technische möglichkeiten
zusammentreffen virtuell
wir haben ja länder gesehen im
wesentlichen in asien denen ist es
gelungen die ausbreitung des virus zu
stoppen china korea japan hong kong
singapur dann hat man den eindruck den
ist es gelungen die ausbreitung zu
stoppen das erste glauben sie den zahlen
ist es denn wirklich gelungen also das
hängt von land zu land aber wenn sich
südkorea anschaut das ist ja auch ein
sehr demokratisch sehr offenes land den
zahlen glaube ich schon und die haben
keine ausgangssperre gehabt und die
haben sehr gut sind sie eigentlich über
haben die anderen methoden durch
praxisnah denter übertragen auf
deutschland was südkorea gemacht hat was
wir noch nicht genug machen ist testen
sie haben sehr aggressiv menschen
getestet und kontaktpersonen
nachvollzogen die konten kontaktpersonen
auch getestet und sie hat sind die
strategie gefahren genau herauszufinden
wer infiziertes und wer isoliert werden
muss